this is the question now where we did
divisive liam proves yesterday i didn't
do a question like this because it is
extraordinarily unlikely that you will
encounter a question like this just
cause it's mean it's so mean but it's
totally doable which is what i want to
do with you now and i've got just about
ten minutes I reckon we can handle it
okay so think back to what it means to
do a divisibility proof you've got
something you want to show that it can
be divided by something else
evenly however what we're looking at
here is quite different to what we had
before this is not a number it's a
function it's a polynomial in fact and
we're showing that it's divisible by
some other polynomial namely that linear
one X minus one okay so a lot of this
will be similar like the overall
structure of an induction proof but a
couple of other little things will be
different because it's not numerical
division it's polynomial division so
let's quickly go through the normal
steps that we go through with induction
you've got your first value of n for
which this is suitable which is um you
can test N equals 2 so when you have a
go at that you would say well the left
well X to the N minus 1 will be x
squared minus 1 to show that it's
divisible you factorize factorization
divisibility we know these go
hand-in-hand
so this is just differences squares I
apologize I'm just going to give you the
quick version rather than talk through
every point have I shown that this is
divisible by X minus 1 and the answer is
yes this thing over here is a factor and
so even though it's not a number like in
numerical divisibility that's it I can
say this guy is divisible by X minus 1 I
can make it super clear by saying look
it's X minus 1 times some other
polynomial do you remember this time
we're doing factor theorem a theorem all
that so therefore I've done ok I'm now
going to do the assumption so it's going
to be X to the K minus 1 now I'm going
to jump on this line that I just wrote
here if it's X to the K minus 1 really
is divisible by X minus 1
I should be able to write it in the same
form as one I had before right namely X
minus 1 times some other polynomial I'm
gonna call this 1 cubed right so this is
my assumption where Q is a polynomial I
suppose I should write that
please note Q is just a stand-in for a
whole polynomial that's why I write Q of
X what am I trying to prove off of this
well I want the next step over the X to
the k plus 1 step I want to show that
it's divisible as well X minus 1 times
well again it's a different polynomial I
don't know what it is so I'm just going
to call it ah okay now rewinding back to
divisibility proofs I'm just gonna have
a look at this left hand side here comes
the proof I'm going to look at this left
hand side and I'm going to try and twist
and turn it so that it looks like my
assumption right and it doesn't take too
much even though it looks really
different to what we've been doing
numerically this is the left hand side I
noticed that in this X to the k plus 1
hidden inside there is an X to the K
right I only have to do one thing to
sort of tease it out it's x times X to
the K you're all right with that
that's what the +1 means in the index
and then there's a minus 1 hanging out
on the side okay now this is good this
is progress I've got next to the K but I
actually don't have an X to the K by
itself I have an X to the K minus 1 okay
now look at this with me right if in
fact I want this to be X to the K minus
1 if I subtract 1 from that because
there's an X out the side here what I've
actually subtracted from this line is X
do you agree with that I've seen this
and this is I've subtracted X which
means that in order to keep this all
nice and balanced right I've got to add
X to compensate are you ok with that
so here is the subtraction of X and
here's the addition of X so everything
balance I'm back in equation land where
everything has to stay exactly the same
and that minus one still hang it out on
the side okay
now what am I trying to show I'm trying
to show that X minus 1 is a factor of
the whole thing right I've already got
something really nice which I noticed
I'm gonna highlight in another color
which is look on the right-hand side
what has just emerged then I'm
interested in for this particular proof
X minus 1 look at that BAM right there
that pot divisible by X minus 1 you'd be
how do I deal with this what am I going
to use it's a proof by induction right
what's the main thing that makes proof
by induction special that's unique it's
the assumption which I haven't used yet
right so I'm gonna say that my
assumption is that this thing is
writable in this form X minus 1 times a
polynomial by assumption I'm pretty much
there right what I want to end up with
is X minus 1 times a polynomial and I
can see there's an X minus 1 here and an
X minus 1 there so I can take that out
as a common factor
what does it leave me with on the inside
it looks like I've got X times Q of X
whatever that happens to be plus what's
left over on the end just just a 1 now I
don't know what any of this is but when
you multiply a polynomial by X it's
another polynomial right if you have a
polynomial and you add one it's still a
polynomial so I've done this is my X
minus 1 times our polynomial and that's
just that one happens to be okay so you
could finish off the rest of it it does
look a bit different but it's totally
within reach just if you remember back
to the stuff you did with polynomials
last year okay